أه وزير الخارجية توني بلينكن
قال أه لقد قُتل عدد كبير جدًا من
المدنيين الفلسطينيين ما هو
ردك على ذلك
أعتقد أن أي خسارة مدنية هي
مأساة وينبغي
إلقاء اللوم بشكل مباشر على كاماس لأنه
يمنعهم من مغادرة  منطقة الحرب
أحيانًا تحت تهديد السلاح أطلقت النار على
المنطقة الآمنة والممر الآمن الذي
أه أنشأناه منذ بضعة أيام لمنع
الفلسطينيين من مغادرة طريق الهرم
وتضع الصواريخ داخل المستشفيات المدرسية
ولديها أنفاق أسفل أسرة الأطفال
وهذا ما نتعامل معه  من
الواضح أننا لا نستطيع أن نمنحهم حصانة
لأن إسرائيل ليست حماس. إسرائيل
تفعل كل ما في وسعها لأخذ ذلك
في
الاعتبار وتجنب أكثر من ذلك
وأكثر من ذلك، فنحن نحاول
تقليل الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين نتيجة
لعملنا البري.  أعتقد أن عدد
الضحايا المدنيين انخفض بالفعل
لأن الناس يسخنون
دعواتنا لمغادرة المنطقة ويتحدون
محاولة حماس لإبقائهم هناك أه
وسنبذل كل ما في وسعنا
للقيام بذلك ولكن كما تعلمون المثال الوحيد الذي
يمكنني تقديمه  أنتم هذا، انظروا إلى هؤلاء
المتوحشين، لقد ارتكبوا أسوأ ما
في حق اليهود منذ الهولوكوست،
أطلق عليهم المستشار الألماني شولز اسم
النازيين الجدد، انظر جيدًا إلى النازيين القدامى، لقد
تعرض الحلفاء لهجوم من قبل هتلر ولذلك
قاموا بغزو فرنسا ثم ألمانيا
وعندما فعلوا ذلك  لقد ذهبوا إلى
المدن التي كان عليهم أن يقاتلوا فيها الجيش الألماني
الذي غالبًا ما كان متمركزًا في إيان في
المدن الواقعة في الأحياء المدنية
وقُتل العديد من المدنيين لذا من هو
اللوم الذي تم إلقاء اللوم عليه لأنهم يقولون حسنًا إن
النازيين عمال والحلفاء
مخطئون  يجب على الحلفاء التوقف عن القتال أو
قالوا استخدموا القوة
بحكمة قدر الإمكان ولكن لا تمنحوا
النازيين أي ملجأ، اهزموا النازيين
وهو ما نفعله يا رئيس الوزراء
باستخدام القوة بأكثر الطرق حكمة
ولكن علينا هزيمة هؤلاء  نازيون جدد
وسنقوم من أجلنا ومن أجلك
أيضًا يا رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو أه
أحد الأسئلة الآن هو عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالرهائن هو ما إذا كان يمكن أن
يكون هناك مفاوضات تعمل على التوصل إلى
صفقة لتحرير مجموعات كبيرة من
الرهائن في  إن مقابل
وقف دائم للقتال لمدة أيام هو أمر
مقبول بالنسبة لكم، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك، فما هي مدة
التوقف التي ستكون إسرائيل على استعداد
للسماح بها؟ لقد قلت إننا سنواصل
المعركة لتدمير حماس حتى نهايتها،
لكنني قلت أيضًا إن  وقف إطلاق النار الوحيد
الذي نعتبره أه هو الذي
يتم فيه إطلاق سراح رهائننا أه
ويبقى هذا صحيحا لا يعني
أننا لا نستطيع أن نعطي وقفة إنسانية لبضع
ساعات في مكان
زمان ومكان محددين  تريد أن يكون لديك
ممر إنساني وأن
يغادر الناس بأمان، لقد فعلنا ذلك وغادر
مئات الآلاف
القتال Z، فإلى متى ستكون على
استعداد لتقديم
الدعم بشكل جيد حتى الآن، لقد تعاملنا مع
بضع ساعات إذا كنت  "نحن نتحدث عن
وقف إطلاق النار حسنًا، لن أخوض في
ذلك لا، أنا لا أتحدث عن
وقف إطلاق النار فقط أيام توقف أطول على سبيل
المثال، هذا ليس هذا ليس توقفًا مؤقتًا إذا
كنت تتحدث عن وقف
القتال فهذا بالضبط  ما يريده كاماس
يريد كاماس سلسلة لا نهاية لها من التوقفات
التي تبدد المعركة
ضدهم بشكل أساسي، كما هو الحال مع الألمان بعد
نورماندي، كما تعلمون يقولون حسنًا، دعونا نحصل على
قيصر، يا رفاق، توقفوا،
دعونا نجدد إمداداتنا، دعونا نخرج
من إرهابنا  الأنفاق تسمح لنا أه أه
بإعادة تسليح أنفسنا وهكذا من الواضح
أننا لن نفعل ما تقوله الولايات المتحدة
من أجل التوصل إلى
وقف لإطلاق النار أي أه أه وقف إطلاق النار في
المنطقة بأكملها والذي سيتطلب
إطلاق سراح رهائننا الأمريكيين  يقول أنك
بحاجة إلى وقفة مطولة من أجل
إخراج الرهائن، ألا
تعتقد ذلك جيدًا، حسنًا، نحن
لا نختلف مع ذلك، نحن
بحاجة إلى إخراج الرهائن حسنًا، لقد كان لدي
عدة أشخاص  داخل إسرائيل
يتواصلون معي وهم يعلمون أنني سأجري
مقابلة معك ويقولون إن الشيء الوحيد الذي
يريدون سماعه منك هو أنك تتحمل
المسؤولية الشخصية عن الفشل في
منع هجمات 7 أكتوبر
وحماية شعبك، وأنا أعلم أنك تقول أنه حان
الوقت لذلك  سيأتي ذلك بعد
الحرب، لماذا لا تتحمل المسؤولية
الآن؟ لقد تناولت ذلك بالفعل
مرات عديدة وقلت إن هذا السؤال برمته
سيتم تناوله بعد الحرب تمامًا كما
سيسأل الناس حسنًا، هل سأل الناس
فرانكلين روزلت بعد بيرل هاربور هذا
السؤال  هل سأل الناس جورج بوش
بعد الهجوم المفاجئ في 11 نوفمبر،
انظروا، إنه سؤال يجب
طرحه، سيتم طرح هذه الأسئلة وقد قلت وقلت لقد
قلت إن هناك
شيئًا واحدًا مهمًا وهو
وأنا  لقد قلت أننا سنجيب على كل
هذه الأسئلة بما فيهم أنا، وسوف
تُطرح علي أسئلة صعبة الآن،
وأعتقد أن ما يتعين علينا القيام به هو توحيد
البلاد من أجل هدف واحد، هدف واحد
فقط، وهو تحقيق النصر،
هذا كل ما في الأمر.  لقد شكلنا
حكومة وحدة أه حيث أصبحت البلاد
موحدة كما لم يحدث من قبل وأعتقد
أن هذا ما يتعين علينا اتباعه وما
يتوقعه الناس مني الآن هو
أمران أحدهما تحقيق هذا النصر
وإعادة الرهائن والثاني
التأكيد  أن غزة لن تصبح أبدًا،
وإسرائيليان يشعران بخيبة الأمل لأنك
مازلت لن تتحمل المسؤولية،
حسنًا، قلت إنني سأجيب على
جميع الأسئلة المطلوبة
بما في ذلك أسئلة
المسؤولية، سيكون هناك وقت كافٍ
لذلك بعد ذلك  الحرب دعونا نركز على
النصر، هذا هو مسؤوليتي الآن،
الولايات المتحدة تقول أيضًا أن أي خطة ما بعد
غزة يجب أن تشمل
الحكم الفلسطيني وتوحيد غزة مع
الضفة الغربية تحت
السلطة الفلسطينية، يبدو أنك ترفض ما قلته
بالأمس أن إسرائيل لن
تقبل بتسوية.  اقتبس من السلطة المدنية هناك
التي تعلم أطفالها على كراهية
إسرائيل، لذلك أريد فقط أن أوضح هل
تقول إن إسرائيل لن تقبل
تسليم السيطرة على غزة إلى
السلطة الفلسطينية بعد
الحرب أولا، أول شيء يتعين علينا القيام به
هو تدمير كاماس لأنه  وإلا
فإنهم سيفعلون ذلك مرارا وتكرارا، وقد
قالوا لذلك سندمر
حماس. الشيء الثاني الذي يجب أن
نفهمه هو أنه يجب أن يكون هناك
غلاف عسكري إسرائيلي متجاوز ومتجاوز لأننا رأينا أي
مكان  أن نغادر آه، كما تعلمون فقط،
أعطوا الأمر لقوة أخرى
قريبًا جدًا، وسيعود الإرهاب إلى الظهور، لذلك لم
نحقق شيئًا. الشيء الثالث الذي يجب
أن نفهمه هو أنه يجب على
السلطة المدنية أن تتعاون في هدفين الأول
هو تجريد غزة من السلاح و
الثاني هو إزالة التطرف في عز غزة ويجب
أن أقول إن
السلطة الفلسطينية فشلت للأسف في
كلا الأمرين أه لم يقوموا بنزع عسكرة
الضفة الغربية في يهودا والسامرة، علينا أن
نفعل ذلك، علينا أن ندخل ونقاتل
الإرهابيين الذين لا يفعلون ذلك.  إنهم يتخلصون من التطرف
ويعلمون أطفالنا كراهية إسرائيل
إنهم يدفعون ثمن القتل ويدفعون للقتلة
الإرهابيين وعائلاتهم
كلما زاد عدد اليهود الذين يقتلون كلما
دفعوا أكثر أه أه أه أه رفضوا حتى
يومنا هذا بعد 36 يومًا من هذه الوحشية إلى
أه أه  ندين أه، لذلك لم يفعل ذلك في
7 نوفمبر، آسف إذا لم تكن السلطة الفلسطينية جيدة، فيجب أن
تكون هناك
سلطة مدنية مُعاد بناؤها،
يجب أن يكون هناك شيء آخر وإلا فإننا
نقع في نفس حفرة الأرانب أه
ونحن'  ستكون لدينا نفس
النتيجة، تذكر أن السلطة الفلسطينية كانت موجودة بالفعل في
غزة عندما غادرت إسرائيل غزة وسلمت
المفاتيح إلى السلطة الفلسطينية وما حدث
خلال فترة زمنية قصيرة جدًا استولت عليها حماس طردتهم،
ولم يكونوا على استعداد
لمحاربة حماس، فلا يزال هناك  ليسوا على استعداد
لمحاربة الكباس، لذلك يجب أن يكون لديك
نوع من السلطة الفلسطينية المدنية
التي تكون على استعداد لمحاربة
الإرهابيين والتعليم، والأهم من ذلك
يجب أن تعلم أطفالهم من أجل مستقبل
من السلام والتعاون والسلام والتعاون المزدهر
مع إسرائيل وليس
إبادة إسرائيل وما إلى ذلك.  حتى الآن
لم يحدث ذلك، يقع عبء الإثبات
على عاتق السلطة الفلسطينية وقد فشلوا في كل خطوة.
أقول ذلك للأسف ولكن بصراحة،
علينا أن نكون واقعيين بشأن ما نقوم به،
ولا يمكننا الرجوع إلى الصيغ التي
فشلت، علينا أن ننجح حتى ننجح.
لمنح غزة مستقبلًا أفضل وليس عدم
وصولها إلى طريق فاشل، دعونا نخلق
واقعًا مختلفًا هناك